and the former adviser to Tony Blair and
Lana barber who is the editor of the
Financial Times very carefully worded
story you say he's stepping back from
this world does that mean you expect him
to give it up this week or his present
role is no longer tenable he's
understood that high-profile role
seeking to focus on economic development
in the Palestinian territories but also
with a political role at the same time
and the fact is that the relationship
between Mr Blair and key Palestinian
leaders has broken down mr. with
President Abbas that shot also the
Europeans we have a new Italian High
Representative have given up on mr.
Blair and there are some people close to
the Secretary of State who also don't
think that Mr Blair is effective having
said that mr. Blair is very keen to
remain engaged and to be given some kind
of job even if it's very informal he's
been doing this for eight years now has
it been a bit of a waste of time to be
honest no it hasn't look the role has
been described in the media as the sort
of quote-unquote peace envoy in reality
his role was never to do a sort of
northern island style negotiation his
role was to focus on the economic
development of the Palestinian Authority
to prepare the Palestinians for
statehood and have been some successes
but it's no secret that he would have
liked that work to have progressed far
further and far first faster as you can
see from the speech that he made in Gaza
just a couple of weeks ago where he
addressed all of these issues I mean has
the problem been frankly that he's mix
business with diplomacy personal
business with diplomacy I should be
clear we had long discussions with the
Blair camp and I was also in Jerusalem
yeah eight years ago that Mr Blair
insists that there is no mixing of the
two and that the there he's taken legal
adviser gazebos having said that there
is a sharp recognition that wearing
these two hats just doesn't work because
Mr Blair has important consultancy work
lucrative consultancy work in the Middle
East he's also close to the abu dhabi
UAE the Saudis
and to be an impartial interlocutor you
just can't blur these roles and I think
that's something that's made people in
Washington and in Brussels extremely
uncomfortable this is the bit of lionel
story I'm afraid I fundamentally
disagree with I think the whole business
interests angle is an entire redhead a
red herring but now the migration story
he's got quotes is not the finance well
I'm saying ladies I'm sure the Financial
Times is everybody I shake does he talk
about the Middle East peace or does he
talk about the next contract I'm sure
the Financial Times is perfectly
actually really reported what was said
to them at the same time Tony Blair was
meeting with john kerry in sharm
el-sheikh on saturday to talk about the
role and how it goes forward look
there's been a conversation going on
here that is far bigger than about
Tony's personal role which is about the
whole roll of the quartet as a whole
frankly the organization has been a
pretty busted organization for a number
of years the best route in terms of the
middle east is the Arab Peace Initiative
that was set out a few years ago it's
bizarre that in terms of the
international negotiations there's no
partnership with the arab league with
the broader regional players that's what
Tony Blair wants to use and actually
lose those relationships that actually
are a strength rather than a negative is
Lionel calls them do he's really playing
a critical price in as much as as I
understand it one of the people that he
did get on well with was Netanyahu and
if Yahoo is coming to the end of his
term leaving this rayleigh government
then he Blair's not going to be very
useful conduit Mr Blair does have a
close relationship with Netanyahu and
it's not his fault that many people
resent that he also claims to have a
very good relationship with the new
Egyptian president Sisi and has made
clear that no longer believes in sort of
democracy throughout the region there
are some problems associated with that
following the Arab Spring but I just
want to come back to two salient facts
the first is Mr Blair really wanted a
job after downing street George Bush
gave him that job as a favor but the
terms of the job were never clear Mr
Blair wanted to take much higher cleared
me there isn't it's not where is it
written to the mandate is finished at
the time and where it is you in 2007
pass through have a regular review yes
it's the pet meeting becomes the terms
of this job have never been
clear that is categorically untrue
Lionel the terms of the job were
published in june two thousand and seven
wonders when he was published we've
always been clear on what the name is
understood now and the vet without a
little without political progress the
economic progress is is saddled and it
is very true they're certainly it's
certainly true that there is a
frustration that the economic track has
not been uncoupled from the politics
that's why we need to look at what it
also the case unfortunately that the one
entity who has clearly benefited from
this is tony blair in as much as he's
had access to the world leaders of today
to the lycée to the white house because
of this job and he's also had the
diplomat is a role that takes up the
vast majority of his time he does it
unpaid you know he does it unpaid in
terms of the sort of work that he
engages in you know i know from the time
that I spent out there the amount of
time he spends in the region what's
important now is that we bring in the
regional players and we look at how we
can actually get the sort of politics
and economics work I was everything he
was giving to it I don't believe that
it's not the majority of this time he
has made it but in back 2012 he made 80
trips but recently more recently I
cannot support that notion that it's the
majority's time is quite true it's
unpaid but according and this has been a
story been working on for at least two
months talking regularly to people they
just don't feel he was effective anymore
and they're worried about the perception
spoken about it publicly himself about
them always change in the room what he
says I'm afraid we are going to have
story there thank you very much indeed